il y a une réunion ce matin de
l'intergroupe de l'anub qu'est-ce que
vous allez dire qu'est-ce que vous allez
demander à la France insoumise mais ce
que je viens de vous dire je demande à
ce que nous ayons une explication pas
dans l'heure parce que ce sera pas ce
matin encore autant des explications
estce un moment il faut pas acter les
divergences et dire on est plus
compatible attendez on est en train de
dire qu'il va falloir un jour faire en
sorte que les Israéliens et les
Palestiniens se parlent s'il faut que
les Israéliens et les Palestiniens se
parlent ça veut dire que en France il
faut aussi que ne serait-ce que la
gauche se parle et qu'elle avance à un
moment en ayant conscience de sa
responsabilité et conscience de ce que
les mots peuvent créer comme situation
derrière et donc je vous le dis je
souhaite effectivement que toute la
gauche avance d'un même pas et ce pas
doit être celui de la raison et de la
responsabilité c'est c'est le cas
aujourd'hui Olivier fort le problème
c'est pas c'est pas la c'est pas la
gauche ou c'est c'est même pas la France
insoumise c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
ces positions qui vous posent problème
bah là en l'occurrence je vais pas je
vais pas faire le tri entre les uns et
les autres je vous dis Simp untit peu
quand même il il y a quand même une
difficulté y a une difficulté même isolé
ou en but à l'opposition d'un certain
nombre de de de militants ou de cadres
de son propre de son propre mouvement
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord avec
ses positions est-ce qu'à un moment
cette explication que vous appelez de
vos vœux et qui est nécessaire elle doit
avoir lieu directement avec lui mais
peut-être il sera-t-il fav s'il en est
d'accord bien sûr queexpr doit avoir eu
avec lui la difficulté avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est que pour l'instant en
fait il se comporte en réalité derrière
enfin il est derrière la direction
officielle de la France insoumise avec
laquelle nous discutons quotidiennement
et en même temps lui intervient par
tweet par message interposé par meeting
et donc c'est une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui mais je ne il en a fait un
autre par exemple hier soir de de de de
tweet Jean Mélenchon il a critiqué le
CRIF à l'origine de la marche à laquelle
vous avez participé je le cite le CRIF
en obligeant tout le monde à s'aligner
sur la position du gouvernement
d'extrême droite israélien en acceptant
de manifester avec le RN en insultant
les élus futiles du P
le CRIF a empêché la solidarité des
Français avec la volonté de paix
qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça mais je
dis que c'est enfin quand on a commis
une faute politique on la reconnaît
plutôt que de chercher à chaque étape à
discréditer tous les autres la réalité
c'est que hier nous avons manifesté non
pas pour soutenir le gouvernement deagou
nous avons manifesté notre solidarité à
l'égard du peuple israélien victime du
terrorisme de la même façon que je j'ai
lu un autre tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
où il explique que il est dans une enfin
que il ne enfin qu'il accuse le PS parmi
d'autres partis politiques d'être d'
d'avoir chercher à affamer Gaza et
d'avoir accepté l'idée que la Commission
européenne pourrait interrompre
suspendre ces aides aux territoires
occupés la réalité c'est que c'est fa
sal les pays qui s sont opposés en
disant qu'heureusement que l'Union
européne n pas suivi le PS mais c'est
tellement c'est tellement faux que il
cite Borel qui est socialiste et quels
sont les gouvernements qui se sont
opposés à cette suspension c'est le
gouvernement espagnol dirigé par qui par
un socialiste et qui en France s'est
opposé à cette suspension des aides les
socialiste donc tout ça n'a absolument
aucun sens et il faudrait quand même
retrouver là aussi je le dis un peu de
responsabilité deux raisons quand on a
commis une faute on bien on la reconnaît
et on on ne continue pas enfin tout ne
peut PASF je vois bien queà chaque fois
c'est une logique de bloc qui fait que
en fait on avance sans jamais vouloir
reculer avec qui que ce soit c'est pas
possible pour vous il a comm une faute
politique mais la faute politique c'est
de ne pas avoir dès le départ reconnu
qu'il y avait un acte terroriste et
d'avoir laissé penser que le Hamas
pouvait représenter le peuple
palestinien que c'était des forces
palestiniennes régulières en quelque
sorte et que c'était une un acte de
guerre non ça n'était pas un acte de
Guer c'était un acte terroriste qui
méritait une condamnation claire ferme
et qui ne supposait aucune atténuation
mais on a quand même l'impression qu'il
prend un peu tous les prétextes pour
vous taper dessus pour taper sur le PS
est-ce qu'à un moment il faut faut que
vous tapiez vous aussi du point sur la
table mais c'est pas une question de
taper du point sur la table moi je ne
parle pas je ne suis pas dans une enfin
quand j'ai construit la nupes je l'ai
pas construite pour telle ou telle
organisation
çar je l'ai construite pour toutes
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui à gauche
ont besoin d'une espérance et de
retrouver cette capacité à demain faire
remplacer le gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron et éviter la catastrophe de
l'extrême droite
[Musique]